[Musique]
paul magnette à auxerre
[Applaudissements]
11dans pense d'en bas
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde entend l'émission où tout le monde
peut parler avec nous ce soir
judith godrèche
[Applaudissements]
m
morgan
sans perez
macha méril
mais löw allemagne
[Musique]
jean luc romero
peluches d'autres vins blind test
consacré ce soir au printemps mais la
meilleure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
qu'est ce qu'ils font quand rama tirs
avant de recevoir ma première invitée je
voudrais que nous regardions ensemble
les meilleurs moments de l'émission
précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé et
s'est préparé par monsieur jean luc noël
[Musique]
mme annie cordy certes cela se connaît
as-tu déjà regardé un film porno en y
prenant du plaisir je dirais vérité la
scène jugement dernier à mal la vie la
vie t'as pas le choix tu allais way
après quoi l'euro c'était quoi je sais
pas c'est un truc dans un escalier c'est
fou l'effet que ça fait les escaliers
haima les escaliers c'est un fantasme
terrible avec un ascenseur athènes
[ __ ] de palier prochaine question
c'est pas de moi c'est de allah a tué
inciter des gens à manger du porc
non mais qu'est ce que tu veux dire par
inciter à manger du porc faire de la pub
pour du jambon à settat en fait les
états unis ont utilisé deux fois la
bombe atomique et la deuxième fois a été
particulièrement cruelle parce que les
japonais étaient prêts à se rendre
alors qui faut-il des armées cela me
semble qu'on ne trouve pas d'armes chez
lui si un pays qui doit être désarmée
c'est les états unis qui doit être
désarmée maintenant ne soyez pas
n'applaudissez pas quelqu'un qui est en
train de défendre quelqu'un qui est en
train de défendre un assassin il en
train de vous expliquer mais le des
plans il est en train de virgin ont
opposé quoi je propose quoi c'est pas
moi de donner une solution messieurs je
suis désolé moi je suis été assassiné
saddam hussein c'est ça non mais bon je
sais pas du tout en train d'assassiner
saddam hussein est en train d'assassiner
de l'audace d'essayer commencer
j'aimerais vous dire une première chose
mais ça fait presque 23 ans que j'habite
en amérique et c'est sûr que quand je
parle en français je traduis en pamela
anderson david qui devient rapidement
votre petite amie
oui non et oui non pas la vérité c'est
qu'elle était mon ami avant qu'on a
commencé la série a brisé j'adore l'idée
m'amuse c'est une femme qui est très
intelligente qui est qu a pu donner un
personnage que tout le monde croit qu
est l
oui qu'est -ce qui est pas du tout l
autoroute chose les rockeurs
sénéchaussée une fille comme les autres
elle arrive le matin
et bien alors vous êtes obligés d'avoir
des gardes du corps parce que vous avez
vu les grossesses quoi c'est insensé
véronique genest ce qui est une femme
mariée mère de famille et où regarder
elle et elle a ouvert son chemisier
entamé leur projet
david cet ennui de peut avoir de
girlfriend en ce moment aux anneaux
because semtazone a warm up je sais pas
pourquoi elle avait à ce quoi tient à
gauche de cette balade donc qui arriva
dans la vigueur fin d'année indique aux
allocs exactement comme ça
alors vous dites page 37 de votre livre
sujet de lionel jospin
j'espère qu'il continuera à apporter sa
vision des choses au débat parce que je
peux vous dire moi en tous les cas c'est
que chaque fois qu'il le fait c'est pas
un scoop tant qu vous avez deux secondes
top chrono
oui mais c'est utile au génial ouais
quand on est entrain étrangers en france
et quand on veut trouver un logement
je peux vous dire que ça ne pas
comprendre que le pape ne peut pas faire
de la pub pour la capote parce qu'il a
voué sa vie à au christ et qu'il incarne
des valeurs qu'on peut contester on voit
pas pourquoi d'un seul coup ça
deviendrait un apologètes du cfer sexe
ce stakhanoviste gay
[Rires]
le v
la semaine passée et ses pédales
j'en ai
e
et maintenant
[Musique]
pas
on va
voici judith godrèche
[Applaudissements]
et voilà
voilà pourquoi je fais ce métier
mesdames messieurs c'est pour avoir la
chance d'avoir le samedi soir des
apparitions comme celle-ci bonsoir
judith godrèche non seulement magnifique
merci vraiment extraordinairement
magnifique pas mal j'ai une chanson pour
nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
bien et oui les bons moments n'ont qu'un
temps d'honorer le 18e festival du film
de paris a commencé lundi il se termine
mardi et vous êtes judith godrèche
membres du jury des tiers très fier très
fier en fait c'est surtout une occasion
pour nous voir ce festival du film de
paris parce que ça fait quelques mois
qu'on s'est pas vu la présidente
d'honneur isabelle adjani
le président du jury c'est malcolm
mcdowell le héros d' orange mécanique
alors dans le jury il y avoue évidemment
jean louis livi elisabeth depardieu
elisabeth quin ma copine de rive droite
rive gauche
claire denis la réalisatrice abdou b
jean charles de castelbajac et anna
mouglalis voilà et la maîtresse de
cérémonie pour l'ouverture et la clôture
c'est anne parillaud voilà alors il ya
14 premier ou deuxième long métrage de
tous les pays du monde et le grand prix
l'arc d'or c'est une campagne
d'affichage de 100000 euros
cher que le gagnant verra son film dans
toute la france voilà et ça se passe au
gaumont marignan aux champs elysées j'ai
tout dit ah non on regarde la bande
annonce avant mardi 16 connaît
[Musique]
oh
festival du film de barry projeter vos
coeurs des émotions voilà le festival du
vieux baril c'est jusqu'à mardi mais les
messieurs au gaumont marignan champs
elysées voilà dites-moi sérieusement
vous n'êtes pas peur de faire chier
regardez tous ces films coréens comme ça
pendant des jours entiers au sérieux non
sérieux non non parce qu'ils habitent
requins et raies entraîné à l'envoi
trois par semaine mais vous c'est pas
votre habitude non j'allais beaucoup au
cinéma avant c'est vrai que je trouve ça
bien être obligé d'y aller parce que
sinon entre
les enfants
les enfants et puis que ça mais n'ont
pas pour le moment mais non il ya le
travail il ya le travail il ya le
supermarché
oui et alors ce stade c'est faire est-ce
que vous poussez votre caddie à j'adore
ah ouais c'est un grand moment de
détente aller au supermarché moi j'adore
ça ouais ouais vous est habillée comme
ça non non non en jean baskets
ouais et les gens vous reconnaissent ils
vous demandent des autographes
il ya des titres qui vous suivent
jusqu'en bas de chez vous et tout ça
doit être agréable
bon alors dites-moi judith vos deux
derniers films l'auberge espagnole de
klapisch et parlez-moi d'amour de sophie
marceau racontait des histoires d'amour
dans le premier l'auberge espagnole
vous étés anne-sophie une bourgeoise un
peu un peu coincé qui tombe amoureuse de
romain duris et dont le deuxième parlez
moi d'amour donc vous êtes une femme qui
quitte l'homme de sa vie après 17 ans de
vie commune et trois enfants c'est niels
arestrup voilà et puis la troisième
histoire d'amour qui vous était arrivé
malheureusement ce n'était pas du cinéma
c'est votre affaire avec dany boon
j'ai appris par la presse que vous étiez
séparer ça c'est pas du cinéma ça ouais
c'est ma réalité ouais ouais mais on
peut
sublime et la réalité oui tout à fait
mais vous avez un plutôt de prendre la
chose avec une certaine philosophie
ouais la dernière fois vous étiez ici
c'est en juin 2002 pour le lancement
mais ce sens que vous jouez maintenant
mais non mais quoi
non je sens que voulait arriver quelques
pancartes ou non n'ont pas dit vous
allez lancer un truc là dany boon
c'est pas le style de l'émission tout le
monde le sait bien à paris donc voilà
non mais c'est la dernière fois qu'on
sait que vous aviez l'air d'aller plutôt
bien c'était donc à l'époque du
lancement de l'auberge espagnole qu'elle
s'était juste après l'agression dont
dany avait été victime sur l'autoroute
coups de torches dans le visage des dix
points de suture 10 avant ouais passera
et 5 manito dit serge les connaît
vos relations en souffert ça de sa cet
accident
non oui non pourquoi je sais pas parce
que comme la question que tout le monde
se pose comment ça va bien merci
ça se passe bien ouais pas de problème
non
vous regrettez dans sérieusement d'avoir
un peu médiatisé votre histoire tous les
deux non oui m'enfin moi je regrette
dans la mesure où tout d'un conte
deviennent sorte d'image de couple idéal
et qu'il faut soc 7 vient ça nous
appartient plus quoi et que je sais pas
si j'ai envie de représenter ça et
d'être je sais pas si j'ai envie d'avoir
ma vie
oui je sais pas comment le dire quoi
c'est vous êtes un peu enfermé là dedans
maintenant si vous voulez plus c'est le
couple idéal où pouvait pas décevoir le
peuple français dont vous êtes le couple
témoigne d'une certaine façon mais mais
mais c'est vrai que je me suis retrouvé
à devoir parler en permanence de notre
histoire et de choses en fait on dit
jamais la vérité
non je pense que quand on se met à
pousser des questions sur votre vie
privée
on peut pas être sincère bien vraiment
bien que ça allait très bien oui mais
j'ai pas vous raconter oui ça va très
bien pour moi voyez ce que je veux dire
dans la bagnole c'est quand j'ai pas
envie de 2,2 justement d'avoir à jouer
cette espèce de truc bien donc tout va
bien tout va bien voilà et vous ça va
déjà pas mal oui oui votre femme elle
arrive fait gaffe
m
et oui donc à l'époque vous déviez
souffrir de la médiatisation de votre
histoire d'amour avec dany vous pensez
que c'est ça qui a été néfaste
non je pense pas que ce soit ça non non
je pense pas que l'amour puisse est
entachée au point qu'on décide de se
séparer
ouais et que ce soit les médias qui
décident heureusement du destin d'une
histoire d'amour heureusement vous les
voulez ça aussi c'est à cause de vous
c'est ça non c'est quoi l'histoire leur
sérieux pourquoi vous êtes séparés vous
étiez plutôt à un couple qui avait l'air
de s'aimer non sérieux oui oui mais on
peut s'aimer on peut vivre des choses
très fortes ensemble et puis la nuit
fait que quoiqu'il quoi qu'il se passe
et quelle que soit la la réalité c'est
sévère de mon fils vous regrettez
d'avoir un petit peu sacrifié votre
carrière pour lui non non non non non je
regrette pas dans la mesure où c'est une
décision que j'ai prise il m'a pas forcé
à arrêter de travailler c'était quelque
chose que je faisais comme ça maintient
une fille assez impulsive très entière
et j'aime bien m'occuper des autres
donc voilà en quoi ces soignants
[Rires]
dites moi vous attendrez combien de
temps avant de vous montrer avec un
autre garçon j-pr quand même non voilà
j'ai dit avant de vous montrer avec un
vieux garçon comme ça avant d'aller dans
des soirées avec un autre garçon dans
les premières recrues que people koi
vous savez je pense qu'une séparation il
faut la vivre
il ya un deuil à faire il ya je ne peux
pas passer de comme ça dans une histoire
à une autre c'est combien de temps un
deuil chez vous à peu près ça dépend il
ya des filles attendait une fille moi je
fais des filles dans les boys de deux
jours pendant deux jours elle son
flipper qui au bout de deux jours est
non
et puis en nacelle peut durer ma grand
mère ça a duré 35 ans ah oui ouais c'est
impressionnant non mais il s'agit pas de
devenir
d'entrer au couvent ne se dire que
viennent de se culpabiliser vis-à-vis
d'eux
non mais je sais pas d'ailleurs j'ai
peut-être tort en fait c'est peut-être
très bien de peut-être même ce soir
ça
bien alors je ne reviens pas de règle
jiff godrèche des très jolies
ça fait quand même maintenant cinq ans
que je vous le répète je vois que vous
venez dans cette émission donc
simplement je me suis demandé et si vous
aviez été moche
[Musique]
interview si vous aviez été moche
sévices graves
judith godrèche si vous aviez été moche
quel métier auriez vous fait même ou le
vôtre ah bah oui aller davantage
davantage d'animateur
la région lyonnaise bien laver moche
manade est moche alors si vous aviez été
moche est ce que vous auriez bouffer des
cheeseburgers toute la journée un ouais
ouais bien sûr trop cool et c est ce que
si vous aviez été moche vous auriez
coucher le premier soir
non mais vous moi oui si vous aviez été
moche est ce que vous auriez été plus
heureuse tout est relatif quand on est
aimé quand on se sent aimé par exemple
quand on est regardé avec les yeux de
l'amour on se sent on se sent jolie je
pense que non vous sentez joly va voilà
judith godrèche
et maintenant yu
dans ce sens là
[Musique]
c'est bien
moi
les ai tous comment
ouais si gérard darmon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien en amont à ces gens du sud il
embrassa eisel embrasser ah oui ouais
des femmes surtout
oui les femmes surtout mais bon vous
êtes plus chaque air vo jeu que c'est à
dire couché c'est quoi ça
il a ses petits yeux de gérard vous êtes
couchée à quelle heure je me suis pas
couché oui oui j'ai remarqué que de ne
pas se coucher ça te fait vivre comme ça
le jour et la nuit
deux fois plus pas mal plus fatigant
mais nous il nous reste peu de temps un
gérard donc il faut qu'on en profite
gras vous connaissez gilles godrèche
évidemment un petit peu croyable le
roazhon ouais c'est ça incroyable le
nombre de gens qui se sont rencontrés
comme vous ce soir sur des plateaux de
télévision
[Applaudissements]
en deux exemples 1 1 ap l'agent prend 2
laurent gerra et mathilde seigner bas
alors se sont rencontrés sur un plateau
de télévision
une affaire qui a bien marché et alors
david et estelle à l'idée se sont
rencontrés aussi sur un plateau de
télévision une affaire qui a très bien
marché aussi on l'a vu voilà donc ce
soir beaucoup de bonheur à tous les deux
j'espère que ça durera plus en tant que
oui oui ça change et le le concept de
l'émission est encore confuse et
maintenant on fait la télé réalité on a
vu que ça marchait bien sûr tf1 se
félicite donc on marie les gens mais
nous on marie les stars évidemment
normal un succès public ces classes pour
une si mauvaise idée que ça non plus
prépare le terrain
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'elle est c'est comme commencer
parce qu'on a lu dans le journal que
vous étiez célibataire ça va être
terrible pour vous quoi arriver tous les
looks étudiés où les loups sont entrés
en campagne bien alors gérard la
dernière fois vous êtes venu vous c'est
pareil
c'était en juin 2002 c'était le 29 juin
et le lundi suivant vous commenciez le
tournage d'un film avec marc esposito
comme réalisateur qui s'appelle le coeur
des hommes voilà je fais le pitch s'il
vous plaît vous étiez jusqu'à 7 heures
du matin mais laisse tomber le pitch
alors quatre mecs quatre amis depuis 25
ans époque où il jouait au foot dans la
même équipe de la banlieue parisienne
oui donc à l'avoine et vous vous avez
créé un petit groupe de presse
spécialisée dans le sport 1 il ya
lavoine alors la voix lui c'est le
baiser reflux dans ce film il est
extraordinaire l'après midi va dans des
chambres d'hôtel où il ya du il ya du
tissu et des grandes fleurs au mur j'ai
jamais vu ça
tant mieux pour vous et le soir quand
ils rentrent c'est terrible c'est sa
femme lui dit mais content quand tu mets
du temps à jouir comme ça c'est que t'as
baiser une [ __ ] l'après-midi à ces
violences film en même temps je vais
peut-être déjà peut-être dû le faire le
pitch
alors donc ça c'est lavoine vous dont
kiel avec une femme il la trompe voilà
vous vous êtes divorcé de ludmila mikaël
et vous vivez avec zoé félix qui est une
jeunesse
oui voilà il ya campan campan il est
prof de gym dans un lycée sa femme le
trompe il y a du mal à la fait une fois
elle a fait une fois vraiment lui
faut-il faire il dit non j'y arrive pas
j'avale paru c'est le pur le presser de
plus il ya darroussin du circuit tier
traiteur qui trouve une fille un peu
paumé faut bien dire qui est jouée par
florence thomassin oui c'est
extraordinaire dans le film il a mis ce
mal aimés comme ça le charcutier deviens
fou d'amour de cette fibre
bref on aurait pu commencer par ça bref
bref ils croyaient tous que leur leur
vie était réussie parce qu'ils avaient
un petit peu d'argent il était père et
ils s'aperçoivent tous les quatre en
même temps que l'amour compter que
finalement tant qu'on n'est pas bien je
suis désolé de dire ça ça va vous faire
de la belle n'en que l'amo est très
important et tant qu'on n'a pas l'amour
c'est pas bien mais oui non mais c'est
ça non jusque là tout va bien
qu'est-ce qu'on fait envers la bande
annonce par exemple manito discerne nice
connaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je te jure je ne t'ai jamais groupe
était en retard j'ai commencé tout seul
pourquoi tu crois que suis en retard et
les hommes libres les autres et sommes
heureux et j'aime pas quand je rentre
chez moi qui ai personne
ap tout achat je préfère une chab
j'aimerais dormir avec vous mais je veux
pas être capable de faire l'amour avec
vous et moi je peux m'endormir à côté de
vous sans vous toucher est-ce que c'est
pas un peu vexant je rêve de ce qu'on
peut avoir qu'une fois
en amour pour toujours ou la version
pdci ont souffert c'est ce qu'on appelle
une épreuve et tu dois l'accepter
il est devenu bouddhiste charcuterie ça
va pas ou quoi ça va pas du tout
toujours prêt à te poser la moindre
question
et c'est le terreau idéal pour un
mariage la du fouta fils a du poids ne
fait pas ça s'est mal passé avec ma
carrière ça fait du bien d'être ainsi
qu'une jeune est du genre qu'est ce que
je ferais si j'étais moins consternant
c'est pour 9
on va recommencer à tourner
[Musique]
aux étoiles je vous ferai taylor alors
je me cale trop de boulot ils ont en
gros si c'est magnifique c'est beau
l'amour ça fout les jetons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ton morflé c'est aller bien loin
mais ça va
le coeur des hommes de marc esposito
alors je me dis un truc quand on voit ce
film on a envie d'être copain avec vous
4 voilà vraiment c'est très sympa j'aime
voir des copains comme ça alors c'est un
film un peu dans l'esprit des comédies
italiennes des années 70 ce qu'on aimait
quoi les films de scola avec mastroianni
manfredi gassmann sordi ça fait un peu
penser aussi à vincent françois paul et
les autres ans a sauté à yves robert en
éléphant ça trompe énormément enfin
c'est cet esprit sauf que c'est un film
du 21e siècle c'est à dire ces quatre
mecs comme on a pu voir dans ces films
là sauf que là ça se passe au 21ème
siècle est une chose qui a beaucoup
changé au vert entre les hommes et les
femmes voilà c'est plus les mêmes qu'au
temps de sauter c'est celui du tout on
le dit d'ailleurs on est la première
génération de dunk avoir accepté de se
marier avec des femmes qui n'était pas
vierge qui étaient totalement
inacceptables du temps de de nos parents
de nos grands-parents mais de nos
parents j'ai pas l'impression qu'elle
veuille partir avec mon week-end
mais j'ai deux chiens de chats mais je
comprends pourquoi il est parti d'avenir
des poissons l'accord s'il faut partir
et que ça le petit garçon il est le
chien fait énormément
comme ça les surprend plus
c'est bien c'est un bon truc j'aime bien
les handicaps tu sais dans tous les cas
y faisait félix tu te démerdes lâche
rien et adore la petite ville en face et
du cinéma en bonne forme et pas que ah
bon bon alors alors vous vivez comme
sage landes armand ou avec des potes
tout ce temps sans arrêt comme ça parce
que c'est un coin quand même ils sont
cent à l' ensemble ils voient tous les
jours ils se voient souvent oui on sabre
on s'appelle souvent soit souverain on
est c'est normal lorsqu'on a lorsqu'on
est il ya une interdépendance quand on
est quand on est amis à ce point là si
vous arrive quelque chose vous vous
appelez votre pote il est au courant de
ça va pas avec vous avec votre bronze
est ce que donc c'est un plus un peu
normal non vous allez au foot avec vos
copains moi je vous foot mais c'est un
secret pour vous
mais c'est toujours non mais vous vous
suivez toujours les exploits du paris
saint germain je me pose pourquoi ce
petit sourire moqueur java lui je vais
jouer au paris saint germain
quand ça va bien quand ça va moins bien
quand ça va pas du tout pourquoi et que
ça va changer quelque chose le départ de
fernandez du psg franchement moi je sais
j'étais un inconditionnel de louise
parce qu'un bon voilà donc on sait pas
ça tire à rien regardez la partie au
moment où il a dit qu'il partait là ils
vont tout gagner jusqu'à la fin de
l'année c'est parti c'est une espèce de
choc psychologique
c'est des mots main c'est des gamins les
les joueurs il faut pas l'oublier bref
j'ai jamais joué en alignant je sais pas
il a il a 23 balles et il est un des
meilleurs joueurs du monde il est
il faut qu'ils s'adaptent au jeu
français par sa fille joue ça c'est
l'excusé crc comme anelka à l'ema qu'il
nous comprenait jeune maxime est qu'ils
sont payés des fortunes et parce qu'il
ya des choses il ya des choses qui me
qu'ils peuvent certainement pas trop
dire je sais pas des paris c'est
compliqué de résister aux tentations
paris aussi c'est une ville très
difficile au niveau du foot
d'accord j'ai compris geagea nécessaire
d'y passer la nuit dans les boîtes avec
des gonzesses à se torcher quoi puis moi
non on a filmé
moi je peux jouer vous la voyez comment
la saison prochaine j'ai rarement
champions champions roc
ah oui vous y croyez vraiment donc oui
c'est incroyable mais si c'est pas
terrible dessus ne supporte pas les
supporter une équipe qui perd la vérité
c'est que suit la casse couilles à un
camion suis pas casse couilles je suis
chef des caisses que nature supporter
une équipe qui perd ça peut être mais
c'est pas une équipe qui perd d'abord
c'est une équipe qui est 6e quelle
équipe vous êtes porté l'équipe l'om
[Applaudissements]
théologique est né à paris il habite
paris il va mourir à paris peut-être un
jour mais il aura supporté madame non
c'est mes racines c'est normal oui et si
ça fait combien de temps que paris n'a
pas été magique sur un sur un terrain
bon service et marie magie oui même
quand il perd contre guingamp
non mais diana tigana il est sympa assez
way tigana très bien mais vient de se
faire virer de sega nattawut je suis
content de participer à téléfoot j'ai
marqué une connerie là je n'ose même pas
te la dit rejetant pris au port du
collet la différence entre une [ __ ] et
le psg je sens que ça me fait rire mais
d'une force vas-y époux tels que la
fuite avait pu aligner trois passes en
un soir
bien bon alors je sais que c'est
difficile aujourd'hui à télévision de
prendre parti quand on est un artiste
donc on va faire une interview joker et
et tu pourras vous pourrez pardon je
vois rarement quand vous le voudrez dire
joker ça va
joker vous prenez combien pas un parent
film joker
l'histoire avec zoé félix là après film
c'est vraiment joker
c'est vrai que vous avez perdu votre
pucelage assez tard gérard darmon à
double joker c'est vrai que le mec ce
jour là avait pas été très sympa avec
vous
bon on attend attend avidement allez on
rallume
ça vous fait rire on change d'interviews
bas via une interview beaucoup mieux
pour govou fait à chaque fois d'ailleurs
parce que vous êtes un grand menteur
devant l'éternel d'une interview
mensonge
gérard darmon vous êtes contents d'être
là je me suis un peu chier mais ça c'est
sympa la promo c'est extrêmement
sympathique vous vous teniez les cheveux
là j'ai vu c'est pourquoi a alors c'est
pas faire c'est de faire plus jeunes ou
pour faire plus vieux signaux pour
montrer que j'ai des cheveux surtout que
vous vous trouvez comment physiquement
je me trouve extraordinairement beau
d'un charisme
[Musique]
qui dépassent l'entendement d'une
intelligence nettement supérieur à la
moyenne
comme je suis en train de vous le
prouver depuis à peu près 20 minutes
alors concernant le sexe j'ai rarement
vous avez déclaré parce que bon on sait
que tu aimes le moins actif que
certaines époques
vous savez des cautions l'interview
mensonge j'ai compris que c'est dans les
yeux que ça se passe oui c'est dans les
yeux que ça se passe c'est passé pas
plus beau l'amour platonique
alors concernant la mort vous avez
déclaré j'aimerais mourir comme elvis
presley plein de tranquillisants et de
sucreries et non pas le contraire
voilà ce qu'il veut rien dire non plus
ça
et dis moi thierry
qu'est-ce qu'il faut encore la matinée
s
sur l'audimat tu es plutôt bien monté
[Musique]
et maintenant
à chaque fois que je viens ici d'une
star du porno
voici clara morgane
[Applaudissements]
là un organe julie john raese genre
d'armes en voilà alors donc ça fait un
an que vous avez arrêté de tourner toute
la france regrette évidemment cette
décision clara morgane heureusement on a
les cassettes à la maison on allait on a
les dvd gérard bodelet remus et voilà
c'est bien rangé alors la première
raison de l'arrêt de votre carrière
c'est que vous ne faites plus un couple
avec greg santoro votre fameux jules on
y reviendra d'ailleurs mais bon comme
vous vouliez tourner qu'avec lui
évidemment comme vous êtes plus ensemble
ou tourné plus d'une première raison la
deuxième raison c'est que j'avais plus
envie non c'est une perte pour le cinéma
je peux vous le dire clara morgane non
mais sérieusement je détiens imposer
très rapidement un ouais c'est vrai d'un
succès fulgurant j'ai une notoriété
assez rapide et notamment grâce à vous
parce que j'ai fait des télés
[Applaudissements]
c'est la mission du service public là
non c'est la vérité j'ai fait très
rapidement des télés c'est ça qui m'a
permis de me faire connaître ce sens les
médias rien faire bien alors donc
aujourd'hui vous présenter le journal du
hard sur canal + toujours quitter pas
quand même problème en le milieu mais
enfin non non vous regarder ce que font
les copines vous faites des spectacles
dans les discothèques tous les week-ends
chaque inspecteur un genre de strip
tease améliorer on va dire faut que
j'aille voir ça devant les journalistes
il faut vraiment aller sur le terrain je
crois moi même je comprends pas très
bien et alors vous avez écrit un livre
quelque chose y avait la bouche qui a
bougé et aux personnes qui arrivent
souvent il est en fait il est pas
synchronisés après bon temps morgan vous
écrivez un livre qui s'appelle sexe star
et c'est aux éditions attaquant mesdames
messieurs
[Musique]
alice que je vous conseille de gérard
darmon
merci ouais c'est en quelque sorte la
bible de clara morgane comparaison
possible
c'est une espèce de somme alors vous
raconter votre vie depuis votre
naissance à marseille en 1981 vos
parents coiffeur sur le vieux port
tout un tout un poème déjà on voit bien
l'ambiance est quelque chose de voir m
bagnolet flavio m oui et alors une
enfance parfaitement heureuse que
souvent on dit les filles qui font du
porno elles ont été malheureuse on a en
france pas du tout un bon parent très
sympa le seul choc de votre vie enfin
j'ai trouvé ça dans le bouquin c'est la
mort de votre grand mère c'est pas un
truc bon c'est terrible toutes les
grands-mères finissent par mourir soit
mais moi ça m'avait plu
85e et notre d'autres gens d'ailleurs
depuis la mort de cette grand mère vous
continuez à croire en dieu mais vous
n'êtes plus jamais allé ni au catéchisme
clara morgane ni à la messe non enfin j
allais ceci explique peut-être cela
permettez moi de dire que d'un seul coup
à l'âge de 11 ans le catéchisme et la
messe voilà où ça mène alors l'âge de 12
ans aux fêtes font coiffer en photo dans
la presse locale a en tout cas je vais y
aller en gage du corps chez gérard casse
et expressif selon qui trinque avec sa
bouche
ok pour le week-end d'accord ok on
attendait 4 la cua gérard lui plus que
quatre
et
[Applaudissements]
donc effectivement 12 ans les premières
photos la presse locale 14 modèles pour
des robes de mariée dans une petite
gloire locale de marié il freine
toujours déjà le site très de 14-15
attendait serge ménard qui sert sur
bella est ce qu est ce que je peux voir
ce qu'il vient de se passer est ce que
je peux avoir un petit replay
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
julie et puis un jour et puis un jour
clara morgane c'est le déclic
vous allez au manhattan qu'est qu'un
club d'après midi à marseille au halal
et là vous découvrez vous êtes obligés d
après midi mais c'est pareil en appelle
bien l'argent et dans ce club d'après
midi donc à l'argent les adultes face à
une autre vie pour but la découverte
donne regarde moi c'est pas le même
usage
découverte du monde des adultes et la
transition de l'enfance ase aux jeunes
adultes arrêtés
c'est infernal est ce que régis peut
venir s'il vous plaît régis mais je me
plierai g100 de nom et puis greg à la
grecque c'est une autre chanson police
grecque santoro non si le partenaire de
clara dans les films il vous a vraiment
révélé à votre sexualité comme on dit
chez dans d'autres émissions
oui mais voilà et la première fois vous
faites l'amour avec lui c'est une
véritable illuminations à l'époque à
l'épaule
donc voilà et là c'est là que ça
commence les histoires parce que
jusque-là bon et là vous partez pas
pourquoi vous allez faire du naturisme
mais au lieu d'aller faire du naturisme
chez les naturistes vous allez au cap
d'agde terme est plus grand aucun nom
mais au cap d'agde c'est comme avant
tout un grand centre naturiste ah ouais
donc après la nuit
bon il ya autre chose mais là la journée
c'est un grand son incurie smash les
familles là pour combien d'habitants cap
d'agde et et 25 personnes
il ya vingt-cinq mille personnes qui
baise non je vais lui faire un contrat
non le week-end non mais oh combien
d'arbres
il connaît très bien gérard je suis né
au cap d'agde hérault début j'avais 17
ans et demi à l'époque au début vous
pratiquez pas du tout l'échangisme
vous êtes simplement exhibitionniste
c'est à dire que vous aimez avec greg
faire l'amour devant d'autres gens n'est
jamais avec d'autres gens je parle du
début donc greg rapidement lui en
revanche il est conquis par les
chantiers mais l'échangisme c'est quoi
ces on se fait c'est un structure il ya
des couples qui ont besoin de d'autres
couples pour avoir une sexualité
débridée parce que ça fait des années
qu'ils sont ensemble pour un tas
d'autres de raison il ya des couples qui
ont besoin de d'autres personnes dans
leur sexualité
moi c'est quelque chose que j'ai jamais
ressenti personnellement mais ça me
faisait rire de voir et là vous
découvrez que vous aimez aussi les fans
c'est quelque chose que j'avais en moi
depuis très longtemps
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que tu veux dans les tâches
c'est quelque chose que j'ai toujours
ressenti en fait mais que j'ai pas
vraiment assumé très rapidement je
voulais pas trop y penser et c'est rare
mais ça va j'ai toujours une petite
attirance vers les femmes
oui on à ce point comme un mois voilà
bombay la suite tout le monde la connaît
bah oui la légende séjourne de clara
morgane on la connaît c'est à dire
quinze jours pas du tout un jour elle
boit ovidie à la télé elle se dit mais
le cinéma porno c'est peut-être pas
match voilà au même moment il ya eu
également utile même qu'aux france a
déclenché des vocations
au même moment il ya le salon autre
vidéo à paris elle monte avec greg
c'est alors une vidéo à paris il
rencontre marc dorcel je me porte bien
mais si je la connais par coeur votre
légende - vous l'avez lu avec attention
bien sûr pourquoi d'accord non c'est
très ambitieux livre là j'ai fait très
attention c'est ce que je lis en entier
oui ça m'a bien plu c'est un bon livre
voilà donc il va soirée marc dorcel et
danser sur les tables et vous séduisez
tout le monde et à ce moment là marc
dorcel vous propose de tourner pour lui
et vous dites moi je ne tourne qu'avec
mon jules je ne tourne qu'avec greg
avant ça c'était déjà après réflexion
c'est vrai que j'ai eu envie de me
lancer dans cette aventure avait pas
avec marc dorcel avec fred coppula vous
connaissez fred coppula mais qu'est ce
vous avez jamais aussi des mavs copie là
comme copuler oui voilà un peu coppola
voilà donc vous accepté le deal l'huile
l'acceptent tout va bien vous allez donc
tourné avec 13
cet extravagant voilà c'est le début de
la gloire vous voulez tout
karam la lune car avant tout mais greg
lui comprend qu'il ne saura toujours que
le fiancé de clara morgane
ouais voilà et puis alors le succès ne
change complètement ce grec santoro face
est ce que vous dites dans votre livre
est alors il ya un truc que je savais
pas la grosse information non parce que
je savais pas c'est que ses ardeurs ils
foncent à toute la journée
1 donc on pourrait penser que ça leur
suffit mais pas du tout avec le matin
quand il se réveille
la première chose qu'ils font sous la
douche c'est évidemment pour certains
sur non mais enfin si grave
le matin en se réveillant c'est très
étrange ça devient une drogue pour eux
le matin en se réveillant sous la douche
bon à prix vont travailler et le soir
quand ils reviennent bonsoir soit ils
ont une femme soit ici il se paie une
prostituée sahara est ce que tu peux
imaginer qu'un mec est souvent c'était
les mêmes que les gens ça deviens
complètement obsessionnel et ils bandent
tout le temps voilà
et là j'ai l'impression d'être dans le
coeur des hommes
c'est exact voilà le film c'est ça ben
voilà et aujourd'hui vous êtes avec fred
coppula way et vous dit en parlant de
fred coppula c'est mon run est un peu
comme céline dion parle de son run et je
connais pas fred coppula mais j'espère
qu'il est mieux chrono c'est quelqu'un
de très tendre c'est bon café les
parents dont le parrain ouais ouais
ouais non vous avez une question c'est
personnel est ce que pour réussir dans
le porno il faut coucher
est ce que pour devenir une star de
porno faveur du q est ce que quand vous
rentriez le soir avec grec santoro à la
maison vous aviez l'impression de
ramener du boulot à la maison
non est-ce qu'on refusant la sodomie
vous privez pas les scénaristes d'un
ressort dramatique important parce que
c'est facile d'écrire un film porno
sodomie maintenant je m'en fous
j'aime
j
alors maintenant car à morgane il va
falloir vous confesser interview c'est
le mot est très juste qu'on fait si
[Musique]
clara morgane avez vous déjà pêché par
penser par action ou par omission par
les trois à parler avez-vous commis le
péché d'adultère
une fois on turc ça il faudra voir une
petite julie d'anne marié
oui il faudrait quand même petit but ni
france pour ça on en parlera après en
cinq ans du confessionnal mais je
mettrais bien une petite pénitence mois
pour avoir pêché en turquie à caraman
regarde aller vous avez accompli des
actes contre nature
non jamais car à morgane est ce que vous
avez dit des mots grossiers comme beat
ou couilles
quand une bonne sans reculer ce monde
tout ça pour la brune pénitence d'accord
est-ce que vous avez déjà été excité par
un animateur de télévision
j'aurais non est-ce que vous avez déjà
été excité par un acteur oui
voilà comme keynes ex tard
au calme
et c'est vrai que c'est assez libertines
libertines j'accueille maintenant
vincent perez
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
on
[Musique]
santé
bonsoir judith godrèche gérard darmon
car morgan voilà vincent perez inutile
de vous le dire je vous trouve très beau
pas c'est très gentil et je sais
pourquoi je me trouve bon faites votre
sourire sérieux quand vous riez quand
vous souriez vous avez la lèvre
supérieure
rires comme ça ce n'est pas bien et
séries il fait vincent perez ou bien
alors oui plus sérieusement vincent
perez ce physique très beau incroyable
incroyable absolument pas surprenants ce
physique est une arme à double tranchant
là il y aura toujours des gens qui
préféreront dire il a une belle gueule
plutôt qu'il fait du bon boulot c'est
vrai quand on est beaux s'emmerde or
vous dites ça moi je pas concerné trois
ans le même cas quoi un objet de faire
avec son physique ont travaillé avec
adam dans l'ems profit n'est ce pas je
dit et ça fait partie c'est d'un des
outils de notre métier alors on fait
avec mais vous n'êtes pas que ça c'est
ce que je sais que je suis en train de
dire parce que par exemple quand vous
étiez petit votre première vocation
c'est pas du tout d'être acteur très
jeune vous étiez attirés par la
photographie j'ai même fait une école en
suisse une école de photographie et donc
malgré votre carrière de jeune premier
vous avez fait pas mal de courts
métrages vincent perez avant de faire un
long métrage qui s'appelait peau
d'orange et qui était très inattendu
parce que aux antipodes des tendances
actuelles c'est à dire c'était pas ultra
violent s'il y avait pas beaucoup de
sexe n'étaient pas filmés comme un clip
c'est un film assez à ces boues qui
était très bien accueilli par la
critique voilà donc après votre film
d'auteur donc peau d'ange
vous revenez sur les écrans le 14 mai
puisque le film fanfan la tulipe dont
nous allons parler ce soir fait
l'ouverture du festival de cannes dont
la sortie a été repoussée et le film
sortira dans toute la france le 14 mai
le jour de sa présentation au festival
de cannes voilà on s'est déjà fait un
film qui s'appelait font front oui il ya
dix ans qui fait que des films qui
s'appelait 8 ans ou dix ans mis en scène
par alexandre jardin voilà avec sophie
marceau voilà là c'est fanfan la tulipe
donc qu'ils avaient été immortalisés
enfin immortalise on sait pas on va voir
peut-être pas peut-être que vous ferez
oublier gérard philipe en cinquante deux
c'était le film fanfan la tulipe de
clients 50 ans
51 ans 50 qui était temps d'en refaire
un talent et rajouter mon âge
fanfan la tulipe donc une espèce de on
retrouve chez vous comme on l'avait vu
chez gérard philipe ces espèces
d'insolence pré révolutionnaire comme ça
cette mort que cette c'est cette liberté
dans le personnage jeu vers le pitch
très bien darmon j'allais faire le plus
juteux ya vincent perez voisine oui ils
en profitent toutes les caméras sont
braquées sur nous et donc bien
évidemment c'est maintenant que qu'ils
en profitent pour faire connaissance
mais attends je crois que tu devais
partir en week-end avec judith godrèche
et dakar méfiez vous il dit
c'est un vrai film de cape et d'épée
exactement dans la grande tradition très
modernise évidemment par rapport à la
version de gérard philipe
on regardait pas ça ressemble banny taux
d'is effectifs 46 1962 aussi en civil
combien 962 comment vous dire tout ça
37,8
cette ville cela vous fait 38 volontaire
à trouver d'ici demain d'abord les noms
enfants enfants comment je les ignore
une seule et dernière place est tout
disposé à prendre lisant on pourrait
pour jamais télévision principe je
n'épouse pas je n'ai plus jamais il
l'épousera après la guerre c'est la
guerre de sept ans déjà quatre de penser
le plus gros est fait que l'étude au
bout mais c'est un vin d'une banda janyk
si beaucoup se gênent pas vos oreilles
et vos manières victor chez neiman ainsi
émasculé ah non ça c'est trop en tout
cas épargné la nuque fret mais ses
enfants et on attend sur madame
j'espère ne jamais me plaît beaucoup
bonjour charmant abeilles c'est le
carnet n'est rien à côté c'est peut-être
cette pure comme d'une source libre
comme l'air
[Musique]
enfant tout court devient un fond des
tripes
à cheval
[Musique]
vincent perez penélope cruz
voilà on vend la tulipe sortie le 14 mai
dans toute la france mais la mission
vous êtes parfait drilles espèce de
petit comme ça toujours le nez un peu en
l'air comme ça vous avez joué de ce film
le nez en l'air j'ai début à la fin j'ai
un peu ça c'est un peu ironique espiègle
espiègle oui alors vous dites dans le
bureau de mon agent il y avait une
affiche du film de christian jacq avec
gérard philipe donc était sur le mur et
pendant des années j'ai vu cette image
et j'ai souvent rêvé d'incarner le
personnage
ben voilà oui c'est incroyable c'était
quand quand lui qu'on a parlé il ya
trois ans un suite un déjeuner tout à
fait intime
il me dit vincent voilages et j'aimerais
te proposer quelque chose est-ce que ça
intéresserait de jouer fanfan la tulipe
j'ai vu le bossu et on court et moyen
comme une évidence
ce rôle est fait pour toi est ce que tu
es ce que tu veux est ce que ça te
ferait c'est incroyable de la part de
lui que c'est un cadeau incroyable bien
évidemment j'ai de suite dit oui et puis
et puis ça c'est fait il a mis un an à
avoir les droits parce que c'était
dispatchés entre y avait le 4 est un
endroit un peu un peu compliqué et puis
le film s'est ensuite il est allé
chercher jean cosmos qui m'avait taille
est quand même de belles répliques dans
le duc de nevers donc le bossu et
et il a coécrit le scénario avec jean
cosmos donc ces deux écoles qui ceux qui
se retrouvent en tous les cas vous
traversez le film comme un funambule
c'est vraiment vous avez dû travailler
énormément pour arriver à avoir cette
espèce de souplesse comme ça vous faites
sans arrêt des dégâts
j'ai fait toutes les cascades ouais sauf
une ouais la cascade ouais lie à aucune
question est ce qu'il voulait de un saut
d'une falaise une cascade 25 mètres de
hauteur dans deux mètres d'eau l'auriez
fait veut non alors avec vous il ya
penelope cruz c'est une idée à vous en
avez cherché penelope cruz une copine à
vous et ils m'ont donné j'ai lancé à la
cantonade mais pourquoi n'irait pas
chercher ma copine penelope cruz
on m'a dit très bonne idée appel j'ai
appelé de crs était pratiquement prêt il
ya didier bourdon louis 15 dans la
séance
je tiens à vous le dire la façon dont
louis 15 et montré dans ce pays c'est
scandaleux c'est un demeuré en a combien
dans l'armée on va ici rien il est quand
même les bleus là ils sont ils sont
allés où les bleus n'ont cessé nos
ennemis ah bon alors le bataillon qui
arrive un seul est ok ça y est puis
alors il ya le roi et montrer d'une
façon très négative mais très drôle avec
20 ans il ya un curé alors le curé les
ivrognes les baiseurs drôle de morale
dans ce film un singe bien donc avec ce
film vincent perez vous êtes enfin jeune
premier de le premier plan quel chemin
depuis votre arrivée à paris à 18 ans il
sait très naïve 25 est arrivé c'est vrai
ouais quand je suis arrivé au
conservatoire parce qu'en fait je suis
devenu au conservatoire je m'étais fait
une image du conservateur où tout le
monde était plus grand que moi on est en
fait quand je suis arrivé je me suis
rendu compte
le remarquer tout le monde est un peu
plus basse en paieraient enfants la
tulipe
sortie le 14 mai les impressionner
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant michel tic
michel trip bonsoir ça c'est amusant
vous êtes le qu'est ce qui se passe on
parle devises
non monsieur je vous en prie compliqué
comme nous donc vous êtes le
représentant de la télévision al-jazira
à paris al jazeera qu'on appelle le cnn
arabe
c'est une chaîne qui émet 24 heures sur
24 depuis le qatar en langue arabe alors
sur cette chaîne ya des journaux il ya
des magazines ya des des talk shows
elle est reçue par 100 millions de
personnes sur cinq continents alors en
france il ya cinq cent mille personnes
qui la regarde
mais il ya quand même en france 8
millions d'arabophones donc ça vous
laisse quand même une marche de business
man oui c'est important quand même pour
une chaîne voit la vie sauve et holt a
en france une parabole sur deux achetée
et pour capter al jazeera donc c'est une
chaîne dans notre pays qui marche très
très bien
alors cette chaîne est célèbre pour
avoir diffusé les cassettes de ben laden
jacques dès que ben laden une cassette
c'est à vous qui l'envoie là c'est un
peu difficile pour savoir pourquoi il
nous a choisis mais quand même nous
avons nous étions les seuls présents à
kaboul en afghanistan
les autres chaînes ont cédé et ils sont
partis ils ont décidé de quitter
l'afghanistan en pleine période de
guerre et voilà en plus belle la d'un
peut-être qu'il a choisi une chaîne qui
parle un peu l'arabe ou via qui
s'adresse à la communauté arabophone
c'est peut-être ça mais quand même pour
nous c'est l'essentiel c'est qu'on a
fait le secours c'est par cela que la
chaîne a été connue rhin quand on vous
appelle télé ben laden ça vous ennuie en
fait on ne sent pas la télé de ben laden
ni la télé de 7 d'un procès la micro
pour continuer à mesure nous sommes la
télé al jazira c'est la seule chaîne
d'information continue pour le monde
arabe
il ya beaucoup d'accusations même en
france partout dans le monde que nous
sommes le relais médiatiques de malades
là on a parlé beaucoup sur cette
histoire je ne sais pas s'il faut
recommencer au pain mais je suis pas ici
pour défendre la chaîne mais en fait
c'est pas ça la vérité il est tout le
monde et quand comment ça se passe pour
sauver une enveloppe avec une cassette
dedans vous savez pas qui l'envoie vous
ouvrez l'enveloppent vous voyez avec à
cette semaine les noms n'ont cessé de se
battre avec quelqu'un que vous
connaissez kaboul s'est pas y'a pas il
n'y a pas de courrier comme en france
qui est quelqu'un qui a pris quelqu'un
comme ça un petit enfant qui vient avec
une cassette
voilà c'est un coursier qui arrive voilà
et qui dépose une cassette enregistrée
par ben laden et nous nous avons le
bureau à kaboul et en diffusant l'envoi
par satellite jusqu'au siège principal
de la chaîne alors cette chaîne al
jazeera vient d'être interdite à la
bourse de new york
pourquoi c'est ce qu'ils ont dit c'est
pour une autre couverture en irak mais
quand même je sais pas s'il ya une vraie
raison ou bien une bonne raison
d'interdire nos correspondants qui
couvre le bulletin économique parce que
quand même on a un autre virus et ce qui
est important je sais pas beaucoup pour
les américains c'est le bureau politique
parce qu'on a quand même dit
correspondant à washington et qui
s'agrippent quand même jusqu'à
maintenant de la couverte de la
couverture pour le politique
j'ai toujours la wii sont toujours là
mais pour l'économie je ne sais pas
pourquoi
ainsi un peu contradictoire et alors le
csa donc monsieur baudis le csa français
vous a reproché d'avoir montré le visage
des des premiers prisonniers américains
en disant que c'était pas conforme à la
convention de genève
vous avez réagi comment c'est ce que
j'ai dit moi c'est à dire tout d'un coup
on se souvient qu'il y à une convention
de genève qui s'appelle une convention
de genève l'avait on a montré des
prisonniers irakiens sur la cnn et
personne n'a bougé depuis des années et
des années on voit sur les toutes les
chaînes en france partout dans le monde
on voit des prisonniers palestiniens
malmené maltraités même en leur
demandant d'enlever leur habitat on le
voit en slip de foie rein et personnes
ordonnées mois mais faut pas exagérer
donc c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas là ici
pour polémiquer sur ce problème vous
l'avez pas vu ces images pts je connais
votre notre cher monsieur l'abbé
deschamps je ne dis pas que ce soit le
fleuron de l'objectivité mais je connais
votre chaîne vous êtes comme toute
réponse vous avez la seule réponse que
vous apportez si nous ont montré le la
veille nous ont montré des prisonniers
irakiens devraient les ont pas montré
morts et puis s'ils l'ont fait c'est une
faute
on parle des prisonniers la convention
de genève elle parle pas de la réalité
cruelle de la guerre c'est à dire j'ai
fait une faute parce que l'autre mène a
fait une faute c'est tout le monde a
montré les chaînes françaises en anglais
est hors de prix en plus sont pas nos
images c'est la télé irakienne qui a
écrit ça brille à filmer en plus il y
avait de la désinformation en france une
odyssée la chaîne al jazeera qui a filmé
c'est le reporter d'al jazeera qui a qui
a interrogé les prisonniers en fait
c'est pas ça la vérité si vous voulez
voir savoir la vérité
alors c'est la télé irakienne qui a
filmé ce serait dit vous avez
exemple avec les avec les états unis
c'est vrai qu'ils nous respectent aucune
convention et en particulier celles de
l'onu et qui sont allés malgré malgré
les américains invoque cette convention
de genève
lorsqu'il s'agit d'eux oui mais pas
quand il s'agit des autres bien sûr il
faut que ce soit égal que ce nous c'est
à dire nous sommes avec la loi mais
qu'elle soit appliquée pour tout le
monde c'est bien aussi de montrer
l'exemple
non c'est pas à nous de montrer
exemple et rondelle est parfait c'est
une c'est une belle phrase c'est bien ça
va parce que les autres ne font pas
comme il faut faire qu'il faut faire
comme les autres on valoir monsieur c il
ya quand même la réalité cruelle de la
guerre
nous nous présentons les images les
informations telles qu'elles viennent
elles
c'est notre honneur vous allez flouter
les visages des prisonniers a besoin
maintenant
à partir de maintenant est ce que vous
allez rester csa japonais monsieur à 10
ans le csa il a dit qu'il va saisir son
homologue britannique et ses homologues
européens pour qu'il y ait une position
commune pour qu'ils aient une position
commune que ce soit adoptée pour tout le
monde
oui en fait voilà il faut que la france
n'en fasse des grésillons oui vous en
foutez parce que toute façon vos images
elles arrivent par satellite
elles sont captés par des paraboles
l'avis du csa en fait vous en foutez non
non on a notre convention pour la
diffusion européenne
le csa elle peut il peut nous
sanctionner et nos rêves et de diffuser
en europe voilà sur le calme et par
satellite
ça y est tout le monde peut la capter
mais maintenant parce que je les râbles
l'examen par satellite n'est pas besoin
de l'avis du csa nous n'osons mais quand
même nous c'est respectueux quand même
il faut il faut respecter la dignité
humaine ça ne concerne pas la dignité
humaine ça ne concerne pas ni les
américains ni les palestiniens tout seul
ni les irakiens c'est une c'est une
responsabilité de tout le monde voilà
c'est ça englobe toute la planète
on est tous d'accord alors de cette
déontologie mais il faut que ça
s'applique pour tout le monde mais c'est
l'autre toujours hélas la politique des
deux poids de naissance et michel mais
je pense qu'on sent plus fort qui sera
encore plus fort si vous donnez
l'exemple aux américains la la excusez
moi nous sommes dans une situation de
guerre il faut montrer la réalité
même la france là quand ils continuent à
9 à le faire sauf si si si vous voulez
privé vovo téléspectateurs de la réalité
de tout ce qui se passe maintenant
chaque fois qu'on va montrer les
atrocités de la guerre les mauves
décapité disons-le des civils
chaque fois le présentateur annonce il
ya maintenant des images ou bien des
séquences qui peuvent heurter la
sensibilité de beaucoup de gens et tout
le monde peut changer directement la
chaîne les gens qui veulent voir il peut
voir les gens qui veulent pas voir il
veut pas voir mais quand même la guerre
c'est pas quelque chose de gai non c'est
pas quelque chose de beau ou départ nous
bien alors est ce que on reproche
souvent al jazeera d'être un peu démago
disons d'en rajouter un peu pour flatter
les masses arabes ce qu'on appelle la
rue arabe nous en donne la tribune à
tout le monde à tous les opposants et
c'est du jamais vu dans le monde arabe
c'est pour cela les gouverneurs ils sont
pas très contents et vous connaissez
qu'il ya des régimes totalitaires dans
le monde arabe
maintenant il nous accuse quand vous
êtes maintenant prêt irakien nord s'est
passé à la vérité des faits vous êtes
anti américains c'est pas ça la vérité
nous sommes des fois plus américain des
fois nous sommes accusés par des
islamistes par beaucoup de gens que nous
sommes pro israélien il ya beaucoup d
israéliens qui intervint qui
interviennent sur notre chaîne église
voilà le gardait les palestiniens ce
sont des sauvages et les barbares et ça
passe à l'antenne je sais pas on a des
accusations de tous bords c'est ce qu'on
fait ce que vous dites là c'est que
toutes les critiques dont est victime al
jazira c'est parce qu'ils sont un grand
souci d'objectivité c'est ça c'est notre
souci quand même c'est l'important
vincent
ça doit pas être facile de jongler avec
tout ce qui se passe autour de soi entre
effectivement ce que les américains
parce qu'il ya quand même une propagande
aussi américaine en amérique si je
passais style propagande murdoch où j'en
sais rien en tout cas c'est en moi et en
vigueur aux états unis j'ai toujours eu
peur de ça parce que vraiment une
rencontre au le jeu trouve deux sur la
sur le peuple américain par les médias
se sont vachement servi du 11 septembre
et puis ensuite quand on est quand on a
eu besoin d'un moment de terreur paf
attentats attention tout le monde fait
gaffe entrer chez vous et ça crée une
sorte de psychose et j'ai l'impression
qu'ils sont servis de ça pour pour
justifier leur invasion bien au delà des
considérations sur la chaîne al jazira
quel jugement vous porter sur la
situation aujourd'hui
vraiment c'est dangereux c'est une somme
dans une situation de guerre je sais pas
si vos invités tous des acteurs peu ya
pas quand même un journaliste je sais
pas si je suis bien dans l'ambiance au
seulement des conséquences sur les
acteurs ce sont des êtres vraiment faim
légèreté telle qu'ils ne savent pas
tenir un tel qu'il ya des gens qui
souffrent moi je suis choqué on a tous
on est tous choqués on a tous peur on
sait pas de quoi on parle on est en
impression d'être manipulés à droite et
à gauche qu'on n'a pas toutes les
informations essais et bien évidemment
qu'on y intéresser tout le monde tout le
monde est intéressé par ce qui se passe
pardonnez moi monsieur clic nous avons
nous connaissons al jazeera nous
connaissons cnn nous connaissons i télé
nous connaissons lci tf1 et les 850
autres chaînes y compris les multivision
qui passent des films de cul le soir on
connaît tous sa vous êtes simplement en
train de nous parler d'une chaîne qui
somme toute comme toutes les autres
c'est-à-dire qu'ils essayent de tricher
c'est d'être connue qui essaie de faire
le mieux possible son travail c'est tout
cet s'affairaient jazeera c'est bien on
va pas non plus en faire un en faire une
pièce en trois actes c'est très bon ça
existe et c'est parfait que ce soit la
première et la seule chaîne
d'information en continu en arabe pour
moi c'est là c'est la seule chose
remarquable mais une dernière question
michel kick sk les émissions religieuses
sur al jazeera non il n'ya pas il ya une
seule émission religieuse simplement ca
de poser des questions mais les prières
par exemple en plus c'est pas les
chaînes islami cela il faut bien
préciser si vous voulez arriver à dire
ça c'est à dire qu'il ya des non ça veut
dire pour vous pour vous rassurer dès le
début ça veut dire si c'est quoi
émissions religieuses chrétiennes ou
musulmanes ou juives
non il ya une seule émission pour voilà
sur france 2 vous savez de tous les
dimanches matin à la télévision une
chaîne de ses chaînes publiques les
émissions bouddhiste juives protestantes
et tout ça je dire c'est pas c'est pas
forcément une attaque ne peut que
demander une chose pareille non non non
chercher moi polémique et moi - vous
vous êtes le patron de cette chaîne et
et cette chaîne m'intéresse parce que
justement elle il ya toujours quelque
chose de on est les premiers sur le coup
et on ne sait jamais pourquoi vous êtes
avant ceux qui doivent être avant c'est
à dire avant cnn avant tout ça d'un coup
c'est à jazeera qui a le scoop de vannes
laden qui a le scoop de 2,2 de la guerre
aux jo c'est tout c'est ce qui nous
intrigue mais à part ça sinon on vit
très bien tous cas moi je vis très bien
vous remercie est ce que vous préférez
michel qui quêtent représentants de
jazeera en france aux états unis en
france
merci merci d'avoir été avec nous
[Applaudissements]
mais ce fils
et maintenant j'accueille macha méril
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la channel bonsoir très heureux de ce
plateau retirer bonjour ma chérie ça me
permet donc de raconter un petit peu
votre vie vous êtes né au maroc de
parents russes
votre père était le prince wladimir
gagarine et votre mère la princesse mary
bale ski dont vous êtes princesse débuts
au cinéma 19 ans dans la main chaude non
non beaucoup plus tôt que cela encore
plus tôt alors c'est une période de
l'année où je ma vie où je me suis
vieilli pour des raisons on était majeur
plus tard à ce moment-là genre à 21 ans
et pour jouer les scènes que j'avais s
il a joué dans ce film là il fallait que
je me vieillissaient un peu c'était
d'accord avec le producteur avec gérard
oury et tout le monde et puis plus tard
dans ma vie j'ai triché dans l'autre
sens mais voilà et puis ensuite vous
partez aux usa l'actor's studio et au
retour vous faites le fameux film de
godard une femme mariée qui vous a rendu
célèbres macha méril en jupe cette belle
de jour de bunuel nous ne vieillirons
pas ensemble de pialat ou devenez
productrice vous créez macha film et
vous produisez les quatre nuits d'un
rêveur de bresson porcherie de pasolini
et puis vous jouer dans des téléfilms
dont colette qui vous révèle au grand
public et c'est la vraie notoriété
populaire alors vous aussi publié
plusieurs ouvrages le journal d'une
femme mariée la star joyeuse pâte qu'on
à la maison alors là la nav emploi est
aujourd'hui macha méril vous publiez
biographie d'un sexe ordinaire chez
albin michel
[Musique]
bien alors macha méril vous deviez
écrire votre biographie et après 60
pages mortellement ennuyeuse
une illumination vous est venu faire une
chronique sur deux personnages
indissociables votre sexe et vous c'est
vrai que je m'embêtais un peu ouais
et puis tout d'un coup j'ai eu cette
idée est vraiment qui a été terrible
parce que j'ai frémi quand je les ai eus
je me suis dit ma fille aujourd'hui
c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut raconter
les choses il faut dire se mouiller
celle ci vous allez faire des
plaisanteries non et j'ai donc décidé
d'écrire à la première personne et
décrire cette vie non pas la mienne mais
celle de cette autre personne qui est en
moi parce que je pense que chacun de
nous et deux personnes on est la
personne sociale citoyenne
professionnels et puis on est l'être
sexuée non et ces deux personnes qui
veulent réussir leur vie alors vous
raconter macha méril vos aventures avec
une quinzaine d'hommes je pense que j'en
ai oublié quelques uns à vous dire en
fallait pas fondateur était alors la
première fois que vous prenez conscience
d'avoir un sexe et à l'âge de 8 ans
quand un ouvrier espagnol vous entraîne
dans le sous sol d'une maison en
construction et vous écrivez le doigt
rugueux du maçon passant entre les
lèvres de mon sexe imberbe vous avez pas
du tout de reproches à lui adresser un
c'est ça qui est le plus étonnant dans
votre bouquin je lui en voulais pas ce
maçon espagnol
je suis la démonstration de ce que
cyrulnik ce grand boris irlandaise il
appelle la résilience c'est à dire de
comment pallier aux traumatismes que
l'on subit que l'on n'oublie pas la
preuve vous voyez ce que je me suis
souvenu avec une grande précision de cet
événement mais j'en ai pas fait un drame
c'est que j'ai trouvé tout de suite la
parade de manière à ce que je puisse
continuer à vivre mais en tout cas ça
vous a pas traumatisé non au contraire
c'était sa main illuminé je me suis dit
ah là là c'est là que ça se passe
c'est dans ce coin là j'ai le temps avec
la raf êtes dépassé vous êtes très en
retard par rapport à macha méril
les petites filles toutes les jolies
petites filles ont été un moment où
l'autre agressée t'as pas eu un satyre
quitte à montrer des photos pornos et
toi de pas eu lors des petites filles
judith moi je pense qu il m'a rappelé
mais oui les petits garçons aussi bien
c'est moi j'ai eu moi alors autres éveil
sexualité c'est avec votre meilleure
amie
macha méril là vous vous l'embrassez il
vous raconter ça d'une façon assez
clinique un histoire de votre sexe alors
un contraction du bas ventre de humer
ctions mais c'est vrai ces vagues manas
comme ça banal lycée banal
enfin je veux dire c'est vrai on s'est
rencontrés très très froidement mais
appelle ça c'est fini pour les femmes ça
vous ai jamais repiqué au truc non c'est
vraiment c'était je voulais voir comment
ça marche et d'un baiser blanche d'une
autre bouche c'était plus facile avec
une copine avec un garçon ensuite bon la
répulsion pour les femmes et définitive
en revanche pour les hommes pas du tout
ça ne fait que commencer et alors vous
êtes dépuceler macha méril dans un
bistrot savoyards n'ont parlé du doigt
par les doigts de votre amoureux sous la
table qui vous des pucelles donc avec
ses doigts on vous fixe je pense parce
que 1 après on m'a reproché que je
n'étais pas vierge
alors j'ai j'ai voulu raconter ça parce
que c'est l'époque je lui reprochais où
il reproche bien sûr d'écouté nous avons
fait bonne image idée pas ce qu'était
notre vie et les la différence
incroyable de ce que nous vivions et de
ce que vous vivez vous on y on dirait
même pas que seulement 30 ans 40 ans
cette année et gérard tout quand gérard
10 et finalement les cinquantenaires
aujourd'hui on est les premiers à avoir
imposé des filles pas bien c'est
exactement ce qu'il a dit tout à l'heure
puisque vous avez dit là jusqu'à
maintenant je n'ai aucune histoire du
maçon
il a senti l'absence d'armand c'est
votre parcours qui me qui me transporte
le malouf enjeu même écrire a dit je
crois donc qu'on arrive à l'import une
première pénétration là gérard donc
c'est juste après le premier coup ni on
va dire ça quand c'est normal
alors c'est un dénommé fafih cac 40 ans
sacré il ya 40 ans quand même donc chez
vous la 40 ans et il vous trouve frigide
alors d'abord moi je sais rien du xiii
ignorante parce que et j'avais je vivais
dans une famille de femmes j'ai deux
soeurs et d'enjeux personne ne m'avait
parlé de tout ça alors il m'a fait une
espèce de démonstration ils m'ont montré
tout ce qui allait dans le magasin et et
moi et j'ai été stupéfaite de tout ce
qu'on pouvait faire avec sa bouche avec
son ventre avec son sexe avec cesser ses
doigts la langue est excellent avec son
odorat avec ray avec les mots avec
mathieu ouais voilà les oreilles et sa
mémoire c'est ça pourrait vous a trouvé
frigide
est ce qu'ils font il voyait bien que je
ne l'aimais pas à
mais là le drame vous tomber enceinte et
donc il n'est pas la pilule à l'époque
et vous partez en suisse
et là quand ils voient votre visage le
fameux fafih après l'opération il
comprend juste en vous voyant qu'une
cassure a eu lieu pour vous c'est un
terrible traumatisme à l'avortement
je pense que qu'il soit secret où qu'ils
soient officiels c'est pas une petite
chose pas une chose légère et résilience
de nouveau il faut trouver des parades a
besoin du plus de mal que qu'avec le
maçon espagnol ça vous a quand même bien
mi mai oui parce qu'en plus ça esquinte
et ma vie de femme par la suite puisque
craint d'avoir été stérile à cause de
cette fameuse avortement mal fait à poil
c'est l'époque des aiguilles à tricoter
et alors ensuite il ya ruby qui a lui
alors 15 ans de plus que vous aimez les
mecs plus que vous aimiez beaucoup les
mecs plus vieux parti de maintenant
j'imagine que ceux des plus jeunes c'est
préférer non c'est pas ça moi je pense
que je pense que les femmes
à la différence des zones qu'ils
poursuivent toujours un peu le même type
deux femmes le même physique la même
expérience un peu la même chose est
toujours de soumettre toujours de
soumettre
quand même parce que ça vous rassure les
femmes pour des expériences différentes
pour croître même rendirent et si je
suis la femme que je suis aujourd'hui je
la dois à toutes ces expériences c'est
pour ça que j'ai écrit dans ruby qui est
d'accord tu vois elle est d'accord vient
hélas vous partez aux usa donc vous
allez faire un stage et l'actor's studio
j'allais hollywood et un jour dans une
caravane de tournage très près des
studios que des studios paramount et
voilà
là
non
qu'est-ce qui passe la tête avec une
bouteille de champagne et trois flûtes
et will dean martin mesdames messieurs
et là vous êtes prise d'une frénésie
sexuelle ou des zips et labrador
vous n'avez pas bien je pense que quand
on est un peu perturbé on est aussi
déréglé sectionnant je pense que je
sentais qu avait quelque chose entre
nous c'est bien que ça allait arriver un
jour ou l'autre
voilà j'ai un peu accéléré les choses
c'est un peu lui sauter dessus ces deux
là c'est comme ça voilà voilà un désir
et la braguette vous faites l'amour qui
table il est très mignon et il a il a
consenti comme oui et après il ya eu
deux autres fois comme ça très rapide
oui dans votre bouquin hygiénique a
vraiment il est raide autre chose à il
était quand il avait un vrai problème
physique parce qu'il était un peu de
colle aux faux bien dit mais justement
c'est une question que je me pose est
est-ce que malgré tout l'alcool qu'ils
s'envoyaient dean martin est-ce que
c'était quand même un bon coup je peux
pas vous répondre parce qu'à l'époque
pour moi je n'avais pas de plaisir je ne
savais pas ce que c'était trop le
plaisir par contre la sexualité ne
servait pour avancer 1
je pense que tu peux comprendre ça l'un
d'eux ont quelquefois
[Applaudissements]
e
non
tu comprends que tu vois elle cherche de
la solidarité
tous les mardis
les uns ont dit les choses je pense que
les femmes on est très très prudente
tout simplement parce que les hommes
étaient leur gagne pain la liberté
économique engendre la liberté sexuelle
mais parce que peu de gens relevé dans
mon livre c'est que je raconte aussi
l'histoire d'une femme qui qui est
indépendante c'est une femme qui gagne
sa vie et c'est pour ça que j'ai pu me
permettre certaines libertés disons
alors après je fais vite parce que sinon
c'est est-ce que huit heures du matin à
un paquet à tout cela donc il ya eu un
chien alors charles et vous apprend
l'érotisme c'est ce que façon une façon
comme ça un petit peu classe de dire
qu'il devait avoir des objets sexuels
dans une grande malle nom de qui vous
parlez l'achat qui c'est celui-là un
problème vous savez plus les italiens
lui a non non mais c'était d'amitié lamy
chappuis est l homme qui cherche l
absolu et qu'il voulait une femme
absolue les tableaux nietzschéen sur le
envoyer ses terrains austral met alors
au coeur des gens
alors bon donc on va vite parce que
charles massimo à massy jean pierre
rassam le grand producteur français des
années 70 j'ai gardé des noms pour
situer comme ça les morts les sept
pressé lait bretons c'est par exemple ce
qui j'ai tourné
et puis ceux qui s'y étaient consentants
genre kontchalovski aprilia fabio donc
fabius et le sexe à l'état brut à huit
jours sans sortir de l'état n'ont alors
lui joua grande expérience si un jour je
peux s'en sort de l'hôtel mais là faut
dire les choses match a été vraiment
vite et toujours le match mais a été
victime comme on peut le dire de
dépendance physique vous étiez
complètement accroché physiquement à ce
match oui même si je savais que ça
finirait à jour je savais que c'était
pas possible non non nous aimons nos
élus pensé que ça pouvait durer
éternellement
et ensuite y un comédien très connu très
jeune on vous citer le nom stéphane
freiss jeu mais avaient réussi à
pénétrer
et puis à votre homme d'aujourd'hui sur
lequel je ne m'étendrai pas parce que
c'est vous qui le faites
conclusion la frustration elle pire que
la déception voilà c'est un petit peu
votre philosophie
voilà le bilan est positif parce que je
pense que une femme qui a des
expériences et une femme plus riche plus
intéressante et surtout quand la vie
vous fait comme ça il faut y aller et
moi je voudrais faire un petit message
ou une femme regardez votre caméra
regarder votre caméra n'ayez pas peur du
vieillissement
il se passe des choses extraordinaires
plus tard dans la vie et je regarde des
mois est ce que j'ai l'air d'être
quelqu'un qui n'attend pas demain avec
impatience
voilà ordinaire
et c'est publié chez albin michel
[Musique]
et maintenant j'accueille bill wyman
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
[Musique]
y a pas de temps à perdre didier
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
demain
toi
[Musique]
m
là
[Musique]
le passé
m
en essonne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
holmes
[Musique]
que
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
k
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bill wyman
ouais
delva mesdames messieurs
tous ces titres sont extraits de l'album
fortune l'x des rolling stones bravo
bill wyman
donc vous avez été pendant trente ans le
bassiste des rolling stones voilà de
1962 à 1993 et vous avez été aussi bill
wyman l'archiviste du groupe vous
gardiez tous les photos les tickets de
concert les affiche les pochettes de
disques et aujourd'hui vous publiez tout
ça dans un livre album qui s'appelle
rowling with the stone ce la saga d'un
groupe mythique c'est édité chez eux
pea
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est un véritable album de
famille 512 pages 3000 photos vous avez
écrit le texte avec richard havers et si
la première biographie d'un groupe
vu de l'intérieur c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire et basinas avait en effet
c'était nécessaire évidemment des
dizaines de livres ont été écrits sur
les stoned mais rien n'était tout à fait
tout à fait vrai alors je voulais faire
amender version authentique et avoir une
version très illustré très différente de
tous les autres nationalités car il ya
tout là alors vous dites quand j'ai
commencé à collectionner les trucs des
stones
c'était pour montrer à mon petit garçon
stéphen que son père avait passé un an
ou deux dans un groupe pop et vous y
avez passé 31 ans pensait pas que ça
durerait si longtemps fly on s'était
réunis pour faire de la musique voulait
pas être riche ou célèbre ce n'était pas
le but du jeu et même de faire de tenir
plus de cinq ans et une sirène et pas du
tout se dit deux ou trois ans peut-être
maximum alors je regardais qu'il
s'agissait là des souvenirs pour le
gamin avait huit mois à l'époque quand
j'ai rejoint le groupe
et puis j'ai continué la il a continué à
grandir
et puis au bout d'un certain moment il
s'intéressait plus à tout ça parce que
c'était sa vie est donc moi j'ai
continué à collecter collectionner les
souvenirs je crois que je suis le le
seul le seul membre du groupe fin d'un
groupe des années 60 qui a quelques
collectionneurs mais c'est un boulot de
c'est un boulot de moine ce qu'il a fait
est extraordinaire est vrai que j'étais
frais
or voilà ce que change le petit stéphane
wyman
[Musique]
papa was a rolling stones et oui c'est
ce que je chante le petit s'est fait
alors on pourra compter dans votre
bouquin évidemment la saga des rolling
stones
vous racontez votre départ du groupe
après quelques albums solo dans celui-là
d'ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
oh
vous ne ferez anglais la saint-paul de
vence dans le sud de la france et donc
je m'étais mis à peu aux français il ya
quelques années bien peu de français
franck mais disons que sa démarche est
d'ailleurs tout le monde a bien aimé
vous habitiez à saint paul de vence si
vous êtes devenu ami avec chagall le
peintre chagall c'était vraiment un pote
à vous oui nous sommes restés année il
et les huit dernières années de sa vie
dans bill les gens pensent que vous êtes
fou d'avoir quitté les rolling stones
quand je suis allé dans rejoindre le
groupe les gens ont cru que j'étais fou
de dire que c'est la même chose au bout
de 31 au 31 ans ça suffit de faire
d'autres choses me remarier et je me
suis remarié j'ai trois filles
ravissantes 8 7 et 5 ans est-ce que
trois filles je suis très heureux est-ce
qu'il vous est arrivé depuis 1993 de le
regretter d'avoir quitté les rolling
stones n'ont jamais regretté et
qu'est-ce que quand vous les voyez
aujourd'hui sur scène aujourd'hui sur
scène qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je vois les rolling stones sur scène
ouais autant de public est ce que est ce
que vous regrettez l'humour de mick
jagger quand ils vous disaient que vous
aviez plus d'énergie pour jouer au ping
pong que sur scène il est tous d'autres
choses qu'on l'utilisé sur moi que la
presse disait à mon sujet mais d'abord
on dit que je ressemblais à
l'entrepreneur de pompes funèbres
c'est vrai on disait ça on disait aussi
que je ne me déplace que pour respirer
et on était un peu vrai on disait aussi
que vous étiez rentrer dans les stones
au départ parce que vous étiez le seul à
avoir de quoi vous payer un ampli
j'avais
les amplis et haut parleurs et les deux
autres en plis je les ai donné au couple
était très content du bon et j'ai amené
ces voix qui est électrifiée qui a
apporté la lectrice it et est ce que
vous regrettez qu'on connaisse - votre
groupe les risques kings que les rolling
stones
ça me gêne pas moi j'aime bien jouer
dans des petits concerts avec le public
tout près des choses plus intimes
et puis j'aime bien jouer toutes sortes
de musiques différentes et ce qui me
plaît aussi c'est d'avoir le public à
proximité par sable loin sinon ça je
ferais pas ça je resterai chez moi avec
ma famille alors dans ce groupe les
riffs mine king qui a quand même jifei
celui qui chantait yéyé
ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap a assez
donné
oui puis à bursa et dépit de fenton
ouais gros coeur de procol harum et est
donc vous êtes en tournée en france au
mois de juin et à l'olympia mesdames et
messieurs le 26 juin voilà est-ce que
vous auriez préféré être le bassiste des
beatles c'était ma prochaine question
gérard c'est un génie et un génie absolu
regarde
est ce que vous regrettez de ne pas
avoir fait partie des beatles jenny tu
veux me remplacer
[Applaudissements]
non non je nous étions amis avec les
beatles et le départ avant d'avoir fait
le premier album était déjà un copain
avec eux et nous sommes encore un match
à jouer dans mon dernier album de vie
j'ai vu ringo ya quelques semaines on
sait que quelques mois au quotidien il
va bien il va bien il a son propre gré
du aussi oui il fait ça me fait du
boogaloo est ce que vous regrettez que
les jeunes aujourd'hui n'écoute plus que
du rap
ce que je regrette c'est que les médias
ne permettent pas aux jeunes écoutent et
à d'autres musiques c'est ça le problème
en fait ça qui est très optimiste dit
non pas du tout il écoute aussi léo
ferré et bien sûr macha bertil va
beaucoup ça marche alors marc ogeret
siffler georges chelon est ce que vous
regrettez l'attitude de tony blair dans
le conflit irakien
[Rires]
je ne suis pas membre du parti
travailliste mais du parti qui s'arrête
et quand il a été élu au poste de
premier ministre
je les appelais yogi l'ours on sait dire
dieu qui je monte sur son nom alors
aujourd'hui bill wyman vous vous
consacrez à vos restaurants qui
s'appelle et sticky fingers comme le
fameux disque des stones avec la
pochette de warhol avec la fermeture
éclair vip et puis vous consacrez aussi
au rythme mine king votre votre groupe à
vos livres vous partager entre londres
et puis votre château dans le succès kz1
vous avez un château un et alors on est
loin quand même de vos origines on est
loin du william perks de lewisham dans
le sud est de londres
vous avez une enfance très très dur
votre père était briquetier votre mère
était domestique puis ouvrière et vous
avez eue
une enfance dans la pauvreté je crois
que chez vous il y avait qu'une seule
brosse à dents pour toute la famille
c'était pendant la guerre je suis né
avant la deuxième guerre mondiale
donc tout maintenant que mon enfant je
les passais pendant la guerre sous les
coups quand j'allais à l'école des booms
nous tomber sur la tête pour ainsi sa
tournée tout tout allait mieux
quand vous étiez petit bill wyman il y
avait cinq enfants à la maison et à
l'époque beaucoup d'argent et vous aviez
souvent chez votre chez votre grand mère
qui avait votre grand mère avait un
écran de télévision
c'était un des premiers qui a eu j'ai 15
cm et pour agrandir l'image avait un
autre écran par dessus un carnet rempli
d'eau et c'est comme ça que je regardais
les matchs de cricket
mais les joueurs étaient minimes
miniature quand même il malgré
l'agrandissement
c'est tout ce qu'on avait donc ça on
faisait avec voilà et c'est là c'est
votre grand mère qui vous fait jouer du
piano de la clarinette et qui vous
inscrire au royal college de musique et
quand vous arrivez dans le royal college
vous avez un problème parce que vous
avez un accent cockney les autres se
moquent de vous vous essayez de prendre
l'accent des riches et après quand vous
retournez chez dépôt il se moque de
votre argent accents driessche donc
c'est un peu compliqué comme les peuples
exacte tout à fait une situation
difficile à gérer
enfin la vie est difficile en général
alors bill wyman j'ai vécu en france
donc à saint paul de vence
vous aimez la cuisine française ça tombe
bien parce qu'on va vous faire une
interview fromage ou dessert
[Musique]
alors interview fromage le dessert est
ce que vous préférez
mick jagger et keith richards et mick
jagger est un petit peu comme le celui
qui vous bousculent à l'école la brute
de l'école elle est plus sympa plus
compréhensif
si vous avez un problème
j'étais au japon en 1904 mon père est
mort pendant que j'étais là-bas aimait
beaucoup aidé les autres n'ont pas pas
tellement l'idée donc c'est quelqu'un de
bien quand on en a vraiment besoin de
quelqu'un il est là c'est pour ça que je
vais mieux
est ce que vous préférez votre carrière
solo à vous ou la carrière solo de mick
jagger la mienne
anaheim j'aime mieux marché que lui
c'est vrai est ce que vous préférez
jouer avec les russes et mine king
devant 3000 personnes à l'olympia ou
avec les rolling stones devant soixante
mille personnes au stade de france
le lin pierre rien est ce que vous
préférez être le stone silencieux
puisque c'était votre surnom ou le stone
avec une grande bouche et des pantalons
moulants beat ya ça peut faire non je
préfère le rappeler fait la version
silencieuse
j'aime pas de l'adulation le côté
célébrités et compagnie c'est pas mon
truc c'est difficile d'en contourner une
star
est ce que vous préférez les stones ou
les beatles jeux présents sur scène mais
je préfère c'est les disques des beatles
en studio
très juste il a parfaitement raison
est-ce que la différence est légère mais
c'est ma préférence est ce que vous
préférez les nanos macartney connaissez
tous les deux je m'entendais mieux avec
paul
plus sympa plus sympa que john john
était quelquefois difficile
est ce que vous préférez que je vous
présente macha méril clara morgane ou
judith godrèche à aywaille
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais macha la pression ça fait 16 parce
que ap elle est très heureuse
satisfaite heureuse de ville alors que
les deux autres
c'est tellement attirante que j'aurais
pas l'homme des difficultés rico mariage
et est jeune mais j'ai jamais aimé
enfant si jeune que mon fils
[Rires]
merci bill wyman bill wyman
alors avec erin en tournée en france et
le 26 juin à l'olympia de paris mesdames
et messieurs il a tourné le sont
évidemment en juillet en partenariat
avec france 2 merci bill wyman merci des
racailles
tél
[Musique]
non
tous
du bien c'est pas bon c'est pas aussi
bien qu al jazeera mais ça fait du bien
quand même
c'est bien quoi j'accueille maintenant
jean luc romero
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir jean luc romero bonsoir j'ai 43
ans vous êtes conseiller régional
d'ile-de-france secrétaire national de
l'ump et président de l'association on
est là vous êtes déjà publié deux livres
on m'a volé ma vérité et virus de vie
voilà vous êtes fier d'avoir été élu
homme politique de l'année par vsd en
2001 bah oui parce que c'est un
électorat populaire qui qui votaient
pour un homme politique est quand même
homosexuels sont pas mal quand même
oui mais justement justement on a
l'impression que c'est à vsd un lectorat
qui est plutôt populaire limite
homophobes la preuve que non la preuve
que la société a bien évolué et qu'il ya
qu'il ya plutôt de quoi tiers alors le
10 mars dernier donc alain royer du
magazine gay email a été condamné à 3000
euros de dommages et intérêts pour avoir
révélé votre homosexualité alors en fait
ce que vous lui reprocher c'est de ne
pas vous avoir laissé choisir le moment
auquel vous auriez voulu le faire mais
c'est à dire que je devais le dire
un mois plus tard dans une interview au
monde serait un truc qui seraient passés
au milieu d'une interview à des plus
simples tandis que là ça a été une
espèce de de furie médiatique et en plus
ce qui m'a fait passer pour un pour 1 [ __ ]
en deux mois était pas j'avais pas de
fausse vie j'avais pas de mariages
blancs et serra et et c'est vrai que oui
quelque part il m'a volé ma vérité et
c'était pas très sympa alors depuis à un
autre magazine gay qui s'en est pris à
vous s'était tue qui estime scandaleux
que vous n'ayez pas voulu révéler votre
séropositivité à l'époque et qui
aujourd'hui vous reproche de venir
vendre votre maladie c'est à dire que le
1d un des journalistes
vous savez dans paris canton quand on
est séropositif et qu'on va
régulièrement à l'hôpital on vous on
vous voit et on vous rencontre et il
estimé pas normal que je ne le disent
pas moi la seule chose c'est vrai je
suis un militant de la lutte contre le
sida depuis très longtemps j'ai créé une
association et c'est vrai que je passais
mon temps à et sur les routes de france
pour dire que le sida était pas une
maladie honteuse et dans le même temps
je disais pas mais il fallait que je
sois prêt pour le dire vraiment ce que
j'ai fait il ya un peu plus de il ya un
peu plus d'un an
et au moment où je le dis mais je crois
qu'il ya pas beaucoup d'hommes
politiques je sais pas si dans le monde
y en a un autre qui a osé le dire au
moment où je le dis on dit maroc
maintenant je vends ma maladie est un
peu difficile à conduire en l'air alors
vous dit en parlant de têtu leur haine
pour moi s'apparentent à des méthodes
fascistes m'a coûté tous les mois il ya
un article contre moi en fait même
parler ma mère on lui fait dire des
choses qu'elle ne dit pas on traite
d'êtres méprisable en reprend des
communiqués anonyme
bon il ya un moment trop c'est trop
alors vous publié aujourd'hui chez ram
ses lettres à une droite maladroite
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai jean luc romero que par
rapport aux homosexuels l'attitude des
français à changer dans têtu 72% des
français disent qu'ils sont indifférents
à la présence d'un ministre homosexuels
dans le gouvernement raffarin
non mais c'est une évolution
considérable en disant ouais je veux
dire qu'il ya dix ans il y avait à peine
30% des français qui auraient accepté
d'avoir un enfant homosexuel aujourd'hui
ils sont plus de 70 %
donc on sent qu'il ya une évolution
considérable dans la société même s'il
faut quand même le dire c'est quand même
plus facile d'être homosexuel à paris
que de l'être en province
parce qu'être homosexuel à brive je
croyais moi ça reste encore aujourd'hui
extrêmement compliqué alors les français
ont changé certes mais est ce que la
droite a changé par rapport à
l'homosexualité
je crois qu'elle a changé 1 c'est vrai
que le jusqu'au moment du pacs ou on a
entendu des choses terribles adam
atteint un sénateur proposant de
rebaptiser le pacs pack de contamination
sidaïques par exemple bon j'en passe et
des meilleurs stériliser les les [ __ ]
au bûcher enfin il ya eu des choses
atroces et puis je pense que ça a été
quelque part un moment
un moment de vérité et on a l'impression
que ces derniers mois il ya une certaine
évolution la preuve et la droite déjà ne
réclame plus l'abolition du pacs sarkozy
le 21 janvier a dit l'homophobie n'a
rien d'un fantasme et malheureusement
elle se se développe
tu vas où cet âge là un stage la sak li
zhi souvent sur le tour tu vas dit très
élégamment merci et puis l'ump aussi à
créer un groupe qui s'appelle gaylib
inquiets qui est donc un groupe
homosexuelle l'intérieur de l'ump et
leur en donner les moyens financiers
l'autonomie de parole enfin ça aussi
c'est des choses qui était inimaginable
il ya cinq ans même tout à fait il ya
une vraie évolution et puis tant mieux
parce que d'abord d'abord il faut quand
même un jour remarqué que
l'homosexualité ni de droite ni de
gauche est tout simplement humaine
il était un peu dommage qu'un certain
nombre de responsables de droite
n'avaient pas compris avant la toujours
que c'est une boutade quand même hein
vous savez quand on fait 1,2 pour cent
aux élections présidentielles nasa
prouve qu'en tout cas le mode de vie
qu'elle défend le modèle de famille
qu'elle défend aujourd'hui basse et puis
celui que valent les français alors il
ya un truc qui est très bizarre dans
votre réflexion et dans votre bouquin
c'est que quand les français évolue vers
un truc vous voyez bien les français ont
évolué 1
par exemple un ministre homosexuels en
gouvernement raffarin mais c'est
formidable bond et quand les français
sont pas d'accord avec vous c'est à dire
par exemple le cadre de l'adoption par
des homosexuels
alors là vous dites oui mais c'est un
devoir politique
les hommes politiques doivent montrer le
chemin maintenant tous les cas
finalement il faut faire ce que vous
dites c'est à dire un petit peu non non
j parce qu'ils n'ont non mais je pense
que c'est vrai que l'homme politique se
doit à la fois accompagné accompagner
les mouvements de la société mais ça
doit aussi montrer le chemin et d'abord
vous savez quand vous dites que les
majorité des français contre la majorité
oui mais les jeunes de moins de 35 ans
sont favorables à l'adoption par les
homosexuels donc penser que c'est
quelque part l'otan en fait
bah oui c'est une histoire de temps pour
qu'un d'ailleurs alors en lisant votre
bouquin jean luc romero je me suis
demandée en fait si vous étiez pas de
gauche
non je suis pas de gauche à 6 ben on
passe à moins que vous vouliez me dire
que les questions de société c'est à
dire que l'homosexualité l'euthanasie la
toxicomanie c'est pas les situations
c'est des réponses que je trouve de
gauche banon pourquoi eh bien écoutez on
va faire un test
on va faire un tel
et si vous étiez de gauche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc mairie mélina un tableau avec deux
colonnes une colonne gauche une colonne
droite représente la drogue
vous êtes pour la dépénalisation du
cannabis
ouais alors vous êtes un peu hypocrite
parce que dans votre bouquin vous dites
j'ai essayé une fois
non non j'ai pas dissocier ces deux
trois fois comme je fume je ne sais pas
je m'étouffe et les rares fois où j'ai
c'est la vérité si je fume pas donc je
suis honnête vous essayez si ça me
plaisait je le ferai l'idée de
dépénaliser l'usagé du cannabis c'est
une idée de gauche demandez à jospin je
pense pas non il était absolument opposé
ministre on a chez lui qu'il a proposé
ils l'ont jamais fait
voyant la maîtrise et sur wii à savoir
une croix dans la colonne de gauche
l'euthanasie alors vous êtes pour la
légalisation de l'euthanasie
vous dites l'état laïc n'a pas à se
mêler de la vie privée des citoyens
d'ailleurs vous avez eu près de vous un
dc c'était votre premier amour comme
vous dites sein qui vous a contaminé et
vous dites que l'ayant vu mourir
vous auriez préféré qu'il soit
euthanasié donc vous êtes prêts à
légaliser ça c'était ont fusé du donné
de la morphine parce que ça allait
abréger ses jours des résultats pendant
deux jours il a souffert le martyre et
franchement
lui s'il avait pu avoir le choix ils
auraient préféré qu'on lui donne dans
tout cas de la morphine bénigne dans la
colonne de gauche s'est dit pourquoi
l'euthanasie serait de gauche en brut la
légalisation de l'euthanasie s'y opposer
aussi je suis désolé même s'il me reste
pas par contre est une vraie militante
de la mafia alors l'immigration le droit
de vote dès j ai dit vous êtes pour le
droit de vote des immigrés oui et que sa
communauté colonne de gauche
je vous rappelle que sarkozy l'a proposé
dans son livre libre
il a proposé un beau gars alors les sans
papiers vous êtes pour la régularisation
en amp à tous les sans-papiers du la
régularisation suis pas pour une
régularisation massive je pense qu'au
contraire ça ferait une terrot de
l'extrême droite et je dis pas du tout
ça dans mon bouquin je dis qu'il faut le
faire d'une manière humaine comme c'est
à peu près comme c'est comme ça avait
été commencé à être fait par le
gouvernement
mais je ne suis absolument pas pour une
régularisation massive je crois que on
peut pas se taire au caire qui avait dix
ans on peut pas accueillir toute la
misère du monde a fait une croix au
milieu voilà sur les deux voies l'a
ensuite la majorité à 16 ans vous êtes
pour un way colonne de gauche
j'ai pas le droit de me défendre mais
vous avez raconté jamais comment vous
n'aviez pas envie d'y faire virer de
l'ump mais moi je pense que vous seriez
mis au ps alors l'interdiction des films
pornos à la télé vous êtes contre b
n'attendez pas ce que ça ma pizza y
avait un débat totalement virtuel le
porno à la télé c'est à dire les films
de catégorie 5 c'est entre minuit et 5h
du matin moi j'ai du mal à comprendre
comment les enfants peuvent regarder la
télévision à cette heure-là
leurs parents sont quand même
relativement irresponsable en plus est
sur des chaînes qui sont cryptés la
plupart du temps je suis désolé c'est
pas sur france 2 qu'on voit un film à
minuit graphique à désolé pour vous mais
la voix sitution ouais c'est un problème
c'est qu'on vous aide tous comptables
sur les prostituées ou sur les clients
des prostituées sur personne colonne de
gauche
je rappelle que la pénalisation des
clients c'est anne hidalgo et des
socialistes de paris gré la double peine
ah bah moi je suis pour la suppression
de la double peine
sarkozy l'a proposé de le proposer au
milieu une croix aux mines la double
fête jean luc romero question très
importante parce que vous porteriez des
mocassins alors les chaussettes
non bush enfin à droite ça semble encore
plus de droite s'attaque en plus
est-ce que vous lisiez pif gadget quand
vous étiez petit oui un communiste mais
je regardais voilà si vous étiez hétéro
est-ce que vous n'auriez l'amour avec
christine boutin de droite
merci l'état une droite bas droite
mesdames messieurs dont on retient cette
gauche à bientôt
non ça au revoir monsieur
m
et
[Musique]
en face aux blue jays ce soir un blind
test c'est le printemps et aux platines
j'appelle masia philippe corti à la
maison il
la maison
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
longtemps
m
gales
qui demain
à raison
pichard
les oiseaux et en guest star j'accueille
astrid veillon et ses copines
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir pascale roberts bonsoir mes
plans gentil mathilde penin elena
soubeyrand et vous jouez donc à la
comédie de paris dans la salle de bains
astrid vous arrivez du théâtre là ça
s'est bien passé très vite ça marche
bien ça démarre très bien on va tomber
je suis ravi pour vous je les adore ses
besoins au moins un
alors on veut passer au blind faith le
monde est pressé le printemps ce soir
bonsoir
c'est le printemps ce soir didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut trouver l'interprète
l'interprète attention au fil des mois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y avait passé l'équipe c'est l'équipe
d'astrid veillon puisqu'une les
marmandais retrouver
[Applaudissements]
attention julita attention philip wee
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah non
le premier titre du coeur des hommes ça
a été l'amour est un bouquet de paix
c'est pas mal aussi
voilà c'est pas mal pas mal c'était prix
et voilà attention philippe
[Musique]
vert
oui
l'embellie ça fait combien pour l'équipe
de savoir les échos là et l'équipe
d'astrid veillon et à trois points et
les autres à temps pas trop à podor a
trop attention en pensant très vite
concentrez-vous philippe up
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette année
c'est quoi
m
les leurs
ouais on rappelle là on rappelle les
règles
ouais les autres ont le droit de jouer
aussi pérez pour l'atv c'est une erreur
à leurs enfants
attention philippe partir il plaît
non la solution
[Musique]
c'est du lion un plus
[Applaudissements]
ça fait combien mes lire alors 6 web à
la longue ça va être un petit peu qu'on
dit attention philippe genevois pièce
bourrée non ce jeune homme
toujours pas
donc
donc ça fait quoi c'est incroyable ce
soir c'est
zéro
mais alors plus si c'est réal de madrid
créteil mais attention
brassens ouais aulas
[Applaudissements]
oh
merci monseigneur attention philippe il
fait
moi
juste après franchement
cet effet ce qu'il a
attention danger un truc extraordinaire
turba regarde bien c'est les tondeurs
j'avais reconnu
[Musique]
et thierry et ce à plus de long way 90.3
que j'ai jamais vu ça à mon goût si si
attention philippe
hugues aufray
dalida wakim à l'école gentil c'est la
rançon du salut
et comment
[Musique]
mais encore jardin ventes en baisse
affaiblie 0 1
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande de vous arrêter là je
vous demande de vous arrêter
bien alors maintenant on arrive au banco
donc là c'est chacun pour sa gueule donc
là il ya plus d'équipés là c'est chacun
pour soi
ok d'accord quelques autres philippe
[Musique]
a pas trop jeune et tu la carte
bon les parisiens web
e
[Applaudissements]
à
oui
[Musique]
voilà c'est tout le monde en parle
l'émission tout le monde peut parler
avec gill grunt au jury du 18e festival
me paraît jusqu'au premier arrêt ainsi
julie g en armes ont le coeur des hommes
de marc esposito avec pierre darmon jean
pierre darroussin bernard conforme à
cloud
ludmila mikaël gp mx et ça sort le 2
avril d'un morgan techstars h he had
qu'en édition s'intéresse le 14 mai 30
ans natif de géra psy avec vincent perez
fait des leurres ou si didier bourdon
hélène de fougerolles michel muller est
donc en ouverture du festival de cannes
macha méril biographie d'un ce
extraordinaire c'est chez albin michel
bill wyman hollywood stone la saga d'un
conflit tic en 3000 photos aux éditions
le fait a écrit my back bay
le 20 juin rouve et le vaccin joanes
ville le 26 juin la piétaille jean luc
romero l'état une droite à la droite
c'est chez hans et michel fiq
représentant d'un jazeera à paris et
reporter sans frontières 29 aux
frontières nouvelles opérations photos
de stars le principe est simple sur ce
plateau on donne des appareils photo
jetables à des vedettes
elle prend des photos ensuite qu'elles
ne font pas développée et elle les vend
nos enchères c'est exactement comme les
dernières c'est l'opération des
appareils photos pour reporter sans
frontières voilà alors ont déjà
participé cette année
monica bellucci isabelle carré janot
vincent cassel et thierry en lan mais là
messieurs + lysistrata lecture pour dire
non à la guerre au festival du film de
paris espace pierre cardin
dimanche 39 à 17 heures
samedi c'est à 20h50 et ça s'appelle le
grand blind test était tout le monde en
parle
je m'en fous
c'est
[Musique]
on est
je
[Musique]
il y
il
[Musique]
on n'est pas des [ __ ] empêcher
[Applaudissements]